bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors première question
est ce que le risque sanitaire a été
sous-estimé sur le porte-avions et si
oui par qui
je ne pense pas qu'il a été sous-estimé
je pense simplement que aujourd'hui on
ne sait pas grand chose sur le tour en
un virus les le commandement comme on
dit chez nous a jugé que la situation
était gérable
c'est ce qu'il a fait on découvre froid
et à mesure qu'il ya de plus en plus de
malades et on ne sait pas d'où cela
provient
et puis les critiques effectivement deux
matelots qui se plaignent du
commandement en disant que tout n'a pas
été fait je n'y crois pas trop je je
suis pas à bord donc c'est très
difficile d'en parler d'extérieur mais
je pense quand même que l'encadrement
d'un tel bâtiment sait ce qu'il fait et
appris que tu es mesures qui pensait
devoir prendre en fonction des
informations qui l'avait alors justement
selon amara dont le témoignage a été
recueilli par france bleu selon lui à
bord tout aurait été bien fait il aurait
même été dit que le commandant aurait
voulu mettre ou à la mission et que sa
proposition à oreille a été refusé un
peu plus haut donc au ministère des
armées oui rage peut pas répondre ne
suis pas à la place de la ministre
une décision a été prise de toute façon
il était de notoriété publique et le
commandant du navire avait souhaité
revenir à sa base
on a préféré effectivement continuer
l'exercice qui était en cours voilà
maintenant je ne connais pas les détails
donc je ne m'attarderai pas à faire
porter la responsabilité de revenir plus
tôt ou pas à qui que ce soit alors
justement florence parly la ministre des
armées doit être entendu vendredi
justement qu'est ce qu'on doit attendre
de cette audition je pense que déjà elle
va apporter les éclaircissements qu'elle
aura en sa possession déjà essayé de
déterminer d'où provient cette épidémie
à bord du porte-avions puisque il ne
faut pas oublier que ce porte avions
était en mer depuis plus de trois
semaines
or il me semble sans être médecin que
c'est largement au delà d'une compagnie
mation contamination qu'on découvre
aujourd'hui sur territoire donc
on peut s'étonner de savoir deux
découvrent qu'au bout de trois semaines
des marins soit malade donc déjà
identifié la cause je ne sais pas si ça
sera fait d'ici là mais c'est la
première réponse que la ministre a
apporté 2 elle va rassurer à va dire
qu'avec les moyens de la direction des
centres de santé des armées
tout a été fait pour prendre en compte
et marin le médecin que vous avez
interviewé l'a confirmé il est évident
que dans nos traditions et notre mode de
fonctionnement on prend soin tout de
suite des personnes malades ou blessées
donc je pense qu'elle va rassurer la
représentation nationale sur tout ce qui
a été fait pour pallier cette épidémie
en tout cas le sort le volet est rentré
de mission a prématurément
quelles conséquences pour la marine
française je pense qu'à la date
d'aujourd'hui
tout le monde a bien compris que quel
que soit le type d'opération est ce pour
être mise en cause
n'oublions pas qu'un porte-avions c'est
quand même quelqu'un endroit
complètement confiné avec plus de 1000
et 1700 personnes qui circulent donc
tant que la pandémie ne sera pas
contrôlée temps même d'ailleurs qu'on
n'aura pas un vaccin éventuellement même
si on l'annoncent pour peut-être dans 12
18 mois il sera peut-être difficile de
renvoyer le porte-avions en mission
comme cela c'est un petit peu ce que je
ressentirai n'étant pas marre à moi même
mais je dirais qu'il sera peut-être
difficile de réutiliser ce porte avions
avant un certain temps
tant qu'on n'aura pas tous les moyens de
combattre la maladie françois chavance
et général de brigade merci d'avoir été
en direct avec mon sur rt france
je vous en prie